hallo leute sieht eure meinung und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute ist freitag
aktueller stand wir befinden uns zu
hause wahrscheinlich würden wir an einem
freitagabend jetzt in einer bar sitzen
oder in einem restaurant oder wir hätten
freunde da hatten klein spieler arm
gemacht das ist jetzt natürlich erst mal
nicht möglich und wenn wir auch mal so
ganz ehrlich zueinander sind sie hätten
wahrscheinlich auch einfach nur zu hause
gesessen aber wenn man etwas nicht darf
dann ist es plötzlich umso
begehrenswerter tja so ist das nun mal
im leben können uns alle zusammenreißen
und zu hause bleiben und was kann man zu
hause machen natürlich man kann trinken
was auch sonst
und da passt unser gericht heute sehr
gut rein
denn ihr habt mich sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr oft danach gefragt ob ich
die minister flutwelle ak den robin
schabowski aus how i met your mother
machen kann und da ich das video schon
lange vorbereitet habt allerdings dachte
dass ich ein bisschen später drehe
machen wir es jetzt denn ich will mir
ein hühner die rübe kippen und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mitspielen
und den abend ausklingen lassen ganz
gemütlich mit meinem liebsten das bist
du
dieser cocktail trinken sie in der bar
mclarens in der sie eigentlich jeden tag
sitzen und mir fällt im nachhinein auf
wie unglaublich schlecht dieses vorbild
ist bzw dass man das so als teenager
geschaut hat ich habe das so zwischen 13
und 14 bis 16 geschaut oder ich dachte
mir natürlich wenn man erwachsen ist
sitzt man jeden tag nach der arbeit in
einer bar
der cocktail komfort in staffel 8 folge
20 die zeit reisen
die geschichte zu diesem cocktail ist
eigentlich relativ simpel liebe schreibt
dem barkeeper was marshall trinken
möchte beziehungsweise bestellt die den
cocktail
weil barschel ihn zu weiblich finde und
marshall sagte anja es ist die minister
flutwelle urheberschaft unbekannt und
dann sagt der barkeeper so du meinst den
workshops geht weil sie ihn so oft
gestellt hat haben sie nach ihr benannt
und dann sieht man nach dem release und
bisschen die zutaten vorgelesen hat
welche zutaten da rein müssen und das
sind die zutaten für einen robin schwarz
die ak minnesota flutwelle übrigens
schleichwerbung stream gerade extrem
viel auf twitch deswegen hab ich ein
bisschen rückenschmerzen weil ich die
ganze pc sitze aber es macht ultra spaß
also falls ihr einen stream noch nicht
kennt ich heiße dort mal wanne twitch
folgt mir dort gerne und falls ihr infos
haben wollte war nicht stream und so
dann könnt ihr auf instagram folgender
post sieht das immer und es kommt zu den
zutaten koralm und das ist einer den ich
schon bei drei cocktails die bahn
benutzt habe ja sehr lecker ist glaube
ich kann mich nicht so ganz den
geschmack erinnern die nächste zu dann
auf der karte ist peach schnaps und pete
schnaps musste ich sehr sehr doll
recherchieren denn es gibt ja
verschiedene sorten alkohol und schnaps
ist nicht gleich likör und dann dachte
ich so ja klar im supermarkt tür rewe
edeka oder werde ich das bestimmt finden
mit schnaps also weinbrand ist so schwer
zu finden aber hallinger salta weinberg
für sich mit 40 prozent hat mir den
hintern gerettet den habe ich auf amazon
gefunden also den kann ich euch unten
verlinkten dann brauchen wir noch
vanille wodka und da gibt es von absolut
die vanille indischen und ich habe die
zutaten schon vor einiger zeit gekauft
und mir hatten freunde da es ist ein
bisschen peinlich ich gebe es eine
andere analog nicht auffindbare zutat
war strawberry jam likör und zwar dass
eine limited edition von babys ein
daher gibt es natürlich auch bei uns
cranberries und weil die amis süß mögen
zucker die letzte zutat ist maraffino
cherrys vaccino
marashi know the result meeres kino das
ding ist aber dass diese maschine
herrschen sehr sehr dunkel aussehen aber
in der folge sieht man diese cherrys und
die sehen eher aus wie cocktail kirschen
also habe ich beides besorgt wir können
jetzt mehr als kino rein machen und ein
paar competition oben drauf dass wir so
gut es geht den look kriegen apropos
look ich habe ein glas bei mir das
wirklich sehr ähnlich aussieht wie das
was sie in der folge haben und das hat
mich sehr happy gemacht es gibt einen
kurzen moment wo lilly die zubereitung
erklärt allerdings ist es wirklich nur
ein ganz kurzer teil und den rest muss
man sich einfach selbst ausdenken aber
ich bin ja ein cocktail profi und für
mich sollte das kein problem sein fünf
teelöffel zucker brauchen wir sogar
wodka und dann nochmal das kino kirchen
drauf so sieht er aus wir sehen wirklich
diese hellen cherrytomaten bot
kirschenmann sieht die hellen cocktail
kirschen und nicht so dunkle die kriegen
das hin und ich bin sehr gespannt wie es
schmeckt denn es sind sehr viele zutaten
und ja ich wäre nie auf die idee
gekommen diese zutaten miteinander zu
kombinieren kommen wir jetzt zur
zubereitung
da zeige ich euch jetzt meine coolen
tricks wusste die eigentlich dass es in
berlin eine mclaren star gibt wir waren
noch nie in der mclaren star
falls sie mal in der mclaren star seit
schreibt man die kommentare und schreibt
vor allem wie es fandet ob es sich lohnt
da hinzugehen so für nostalgie alte
serie feelings also der raum riecht sehr
sehr gut der 21 naja dann machen wir
vier cl um als nächstes brauchen wir den
tiefschnee
die flasche bis nach oben hin gefüllt
oha da von dem wir zwei cl war das
richtig was hat party party party spaß
spaß spaß spaß spaß spaß und bevor ich
gleich diesen cocktail trinke ein
bisschen laktase dann machen wir mal
noch mal fünf cl drauf ich glaube
richtig eklig wird jetzt aussehen wenn
wir den saft in diese milch kippen
man muss es gut schenken das stockt so
richtig geht bevor wir schütteln machen
wir jetzt noch fünf teelöffel zucker
rhein zu demonstrationszwecken und
natürlich wie lilly auch gesagt hat ein
schuss wodka ein schuss
der hielt drauf
sheikh said
wir laden zu hause um anderen menschen
zu helfen und getränke einfüllen lux
so und jetzt natürlich als große finale
eigentlich steht im rezept meeres
kirchen sollen rein aber vom nokia sehen
sie aus ihnen cockpit kirschau die man
die proll die sendung natürlich sind wir
aber noch nicht fertig und weil ich so
toll bin habe ich sogar noch das letzte
den letzten schritt den gelben strohhalm
den wir jetzt hier seht und sieht jetzt
nicht ganz genau so aus aber schon sehr
ähnlich und hier haben wir die minnesota
flutwelle sie tatsächlich anfang die
celica aus bin gespannt und nun stellen
wir uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten trage wie schmeckt die
minnesota flutwelle ak dominik hrbaty
aufbau mit jutta ich glaube wir sind
noch nicht wir sind noch nicht an dem
ziel angekommen ich weiß nicht was das
ziel ist aber das ist auf jeden fall
nicht die macht zu anderen probieren
kommen ja du bist ein guter spezialist
für alkoholische getränke
ja das ist wieder natürlich ein tolles
bild habe hallo leute
guten morgen guten mittag riecht auch
hier schon mega der mz geil aber so
cultra süßen dann gleich diese ultra
stark ja wir machen hier noch besser
runde nummer zwei denn wir wollen etwas
erschaffen was wirklich lecker wir
beginnen unsere base einem guten schuss
cranberry dazu
richtig dass es nicht viel mehr gibt als
cranberries dann nehmen wir dieses mal
auch nur einen schuss von dem strawberry
likör ein schüsschen und auch nur einen
schuss von neben pique schnaps vom
coconut ram können wir ein bisschen mehr
rein machen
das war schon sehr viel fünf teelöffel
zucker nicht vergessen und ein schuss
vanille wodka ein bisschen eis
reinzuhauen bleiben ist eigentlich wie
draußen sein nur dass man zu hause
bleibt
ja ja das wird auf jeden fall schon mehr
die farbe wie das original ja das ist
schon besser aus mehr als kino cherrys
also zwei als im rezept steht und kommt
der kirchen war einfach cocktail küchen
und brauchen kann er das kino
natürlich unseren stroheim nicht
vergessen denn ohne ihn kann man ihn
nicht trinken so ist was der hier kommt
dem original vom look feel näher
und jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt und
wir stellen uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmecken die
mir das so dass mit belag hat daraufhin
schwarz mit dem handel
timo com probieren sie das auch nicht
mehr so viel geschick sondern ist ein
cocktail liga war nie besser also das
geheimnis ist dass man auf jeden fall
viel mehr cranberrysaft nimmt und nur
ein schuss von dem strawberry likör und
von dem anderen halt einfach ein schuss
ein vom klub dem boden
ich mach gleich sauber
born herum kommen gut durch man merkt
ganz klar dieses fleisches cranberry er
ist sehr süß durch die fünf esslöffel
zucker teelöffel teelöffel man schmeckt
sehr viel kokos rum und auch den peak so
ganz leicht der macht so den bus und
vanille wodka es ist einfach sehr
harmonisch dieser cockpit ist wirklich
lecker ist eine lüge
falls ihr den nachmachen es ist sehr
schwer denn alle zutaten sind sehr
schwer zu kriegen aber ich verlinke euch
alle unten in der infobox
vielleicht stellt sie es jetzt ich weiß
gar nicht ob man zurzeit bestehen sollte
allerdings muss die wirtschaft ja auch
irgendwie weitergehen und die jobs
sollten ja nicht alle verloren gehen
exakt diese ok-chef leute folgten wir
unbedingt auf deutsch und auf instagram
aktivität die glocke wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder haltet durch bleibt
zu hause
dann kriegen wir das alle gemeinsam hin
dass das virus sich nicht so schnell
verbreitet bis zum nächsten mal eure mal
waren
[Musik]